[Music]
this is all i'm saying
because the holidays can be stressful
but what i would recommend if you're a
man
and you're stressed around the holidays
get married so if you're right now and
you're three weeks from christmas and
you're a single guy you're stressed
about the holidays just run out and get
married real quick and that'll take care
of it
it is it is really stress-free to be a
man during the holidays
um i like i can't recommend it enough i
love it and then the great thing is
here's what makes it fun
is that
um
when everyone's opening their gifts on
christmas
i get to find out what i gave them
you know
so it's always a nice surprise i also
find out what i bought for myself
and it just it makes the whole
experience great and uh it's it's really
it's really wonderful
cannot recommend marriage enough for
many reasons that's just one that's not
the only reason but that's one of them
so you know they say honesty is the best
policy but um
sometimes in marriage
you know i do tend to doubt that a
little bit i have to be honest with you
i'll be honest about that sometimes i
doubt
a little bit i sometimes doubt the
honest the the value of honesty in
marriage and i'll just explain why like
for example yesterday i got home from
traveling i was traveling over the the
weekend i was in austin
and for a pro-life event actually
because they do have those in austin it
turns out it was a great event anyway i
came home
a few hours i thought everything was
fine a few everything looked you know
everything looked normal and the same to
me when i got home as it did when i left
because i left the day before
and a few hours after i got home my wife
said to me
she said as we're sitting on the couch
hey so you didn't say anything about my
hair
and i said and this is where the honesty
kicked in
okay this is where i was gonna be honest
and i said what about your hair
and she said i dyed it
and i said oh
and she said you know it's brown now it
was blonde before
and then i said it was blonde before
and then i realized i should stop saying
things in that moment but here's my
point i was honest for the whole
conversation i was completely honest
now do you really want to tell me that
was the best policy i don't think it was
and then actually in in my in my defense
i actually went because i never know
when to drop it so um a little bit later
on i went back to try to prove my point
i pulled up her
her profile picture from twitter which
is from before she allegedly dyed her
hair and i showed it to her and i said
no your hair was brown before it looks
the same
i was trying to mansplain her own hair
color to her i was bringing facts and
evidence and destroying her with it
but it didn't matter she said i was
colorblind i don't know maybe i am
i am at this this moment calling for a
complete and total shutdown of tipping
until we figure out
what the hell is going on to paraphrase
donald trump now to be clear i i don't
consider myself to be a cheap person
growing up my dad would always tip 20 to
25 as a baseline starting point at
restaurants i have inherited this custom
and will also generally tip 20 to 25
percent sometimes more actually partly
as an act of generosity and partly as an
apology
because i have four young kids and as a
consequence we leave our tables looking
like a pack of wild dogs has just been
dining there except the dogs at least
would eat all their chicken nuggets
which is more than i could say for my
daughter but in any case the point is
i have always tipped well i think
and i've tipped the pizza delivery guy
well also
and the cab or the uber driver
and of course if i'm staying at a fancy
hotel then i know i'm supposed to tip
basically everyone who happens to glance
at me at fancy hotels employees will
invent
weird and unnecessary things to do for
you
just so they can get a tip somebody will
like come to your room at 8 30 in the
morning and spoon feed you granola and
clip your toenails you're supposed to
tip them five dollars and i've always
gone along with that
i've prided myself as a tipper
but recently i have reached my limits
because the problem is that now
everybody expects a tip
whereas before you were only supposed to
give a tip in certain limited and
specialized circumstances now every
person who rings up a purchase at a cash
register or pours you a cup of coffee
wants to be tipped for their trouble
you know the the solicitation for tips
can come
in in only these mildly invasive ways
like you know there's a tip jar left out
on the counter or sometimes in slightly
more obnoxious forms like when you're
handed a receipt or told to confirm your
purchase on an ipad that's a big one now
they flip the ipad around and then
there's a there's you know you're
supposed to click through how much
gratuity do you want to leave
but sometimes and i've had this
experience more than once especially
recently
the person ringing up the purchase will
actually ask you outright whether you
would like to add a gratuity like asking
you verbally
applying social pressure and attempting
to make you look like a jerk to the
other customers in line if you say no
now fortunately in my case
i'm used to being a jerk in public so i
have no problem responding with no i
don't want to add a gratuity or the more
passive-aggressive
no but thanks for asking
many kinder and gentler people than
myself however are guilted into tipping
a dollar or more on a coffee that's
already twice as expensive as it should
be
the situation is entirely untenable
the average cost of living in america
has increased by upwards of 65 percent
in the last two years because of
excessive tipping
don't fact-check me on that figure it's
emotionally correct if not factually
correct so i have to put it i have to
put tipping on probation
banning it across the board temporarily
until sanity can be restored to the
proceedings and here's some sanity
just because you work in customer
service doesn't mean you automatically
deserve a tip
you are getting paid a wage after all
customers are already paying for the
good or service you're providing
here's the way i look at it tipping
should only come into play if three
conditions are met number one it's a low
paying service job
two it's a service that i could not or
would not want to perform myself and
three
my experience as a customer can be
greatly enhanced by your excellent
performance or greatly diminished by
your poor performance so those are the
three conditions
this is why we should and always have
tipped waiters
waiter has a low paying job
and you know the fact that the customer
is at a sit-down restaurant means they
don't want to cook and serve themselves
and the quality of the customer's
experience at the restaurant is highly
dependent on the quality of the waiter's
service a bad waiter means a bad time a
good waiter means a good time
barbers and pizza delivery guys also
meet all three conditions but what about
a cashier ringing up my items at a
grocery store
often they ask for a tip now too
but they shouldn't receive one because
yes condition one low paying job is met
but conditions two and three are not
i would gladly use the self-checkout if
it's an option
so it's not a service i couldn't or
wouldn't do myself and though there are
people who somehow find ways to be very
bad at running cash registers there
really isn't any way to be excellent at
it
so my experience as a customer will be
about the same with an excellent cashier
as it is with a mediocre one
the barista pouring my coffee
also should not be tipped because she
fails to meet all three conditions again
condition one is met
okay
low paying job
but i could without much trouble pour my
own coffee if given the option in fact
at some places they'll just hand you the
empty cup and have you fill it yourself
yet even then they want a tip
the simple act of picking up an empty
cup and doing this like just just that
this is it this is what this is what
earns you a tip now
there you go
that'll be three extra dollars
like you you get a financial bonus for
doing that
this system with the three conditions
i've outlined um also explains why we
don't tip say airline pilots you know in
their case conditions two and three are
met i can't fly the plane myself and my
experience as a customer would be quite
unpleasant if the pilot isn't good at
his job but condition one is not met
airline pilots are paid handsomely and
for good reason
now the only category that throws my
system for a loop
are the endangered species known as
bathroom attendants
they used to be a lot more common than
they are today but you still find them
sometimes
standing by the sinks
at like a bar or restaurant handing out
towels and mints
i've always tipped them even though i
could quite easily grab my own towel and
i'm really not interested in mints that
have been saturating in the fumes of
strange farts all day but i tip mainly
out of pity because they have to stand
there in the bathroom experiencing the
sounds and smells of human waste
plopping ominously into toilets
or near toilets at any rate
an exception was made for bathroom
attendance but now everybody wants the
bathroom attendant exception now
everybody expects a tip even random
people online will post their venmo or
gofundme
soliciting funds for no reason after
having provided you absolutely no
service of any kind whatsoever they just
say hey by the way if you want to give
me some money here it is
it's not even tipping anymore this is
panhandling
and we have to pull back from it while
we still can
before it gets so out of hand that
you'll be bankrupted just by running
errands for three hours on a saturday
afternoon
given recent scotus wins it feels like
the pendulum may be swinging back to a
time when the nuclear family was
situated at the center of american life
where real conversation learning and
growth began at home with your family
gathered around the table in president
ronald reagan's farewell address he said
all great change in america begins
around the dinner table so you got to
bring your family to the dinner table
with good ranchers good ranchers cares
deeply about providing families with
high quality meat at a reasonable price
their mission is to bring people to the
table making those shared moments with
your loved ones easy accessible and most
importantly delicious good ranchers
ships 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the u.s right to your door
plus when you subscribe your price is
locked in for the life of your
subscription no inflation when it comes
to good ranchers good ranchers not only
supports american agriculture they're
also
big fans of the daily wire big
supporters they sponsor all of our shows
so you gotta check them out use my code
matt for thirty dollars off plus free
shipping on your order take advantage of
this offer invest in time shared with
your family you're gonna buy meat anyway
so you might as well buy great meat from
folks who support all that we do here go
to goodranchers.com to start bringing
people back to the table and eating
seriously delicious food also if you
already bought from good ranchers well
show me what you're making post a photo
of your meal i'd love to see it and tag
me and my friends of good ranchers so
they can see it too
i'm just on a plane i mentioned
yesterday we were traveling over the
weekend and i was on a plane
and um uh
fully pla packed flight so i guess we're
forgetting about the chronovirus thing
now look so good so we'll see of course
you have to be socially distant to get
on the plane as we know but then you get
on the plane and you're just packed in
like sardines
um and there's someone sitting next to
me in the middle seat
and so here's here's the kind of person
that you ban i think and if i'm if i'm
setting the rules
for an airline this is what i'm doing
when you're sitting in the middle seat a
lot of times there's controversy over
who gets the arm rests
well i'll tell you right now
and i'm surprised so many people don't
realize this when you're in the middle
seat
you get no armrests
you have no right to any space at all
you are an imposition on the people
around you
and when you're sitting down in the
middle seat and you have to kind of do
that awkward thing where you say oh can
i sit there's anybody sitting there and
you feel like both the person in the
aisle and the and the window seat is
looking at you and judging you and
hating you for being there that's right
they are and they do hate you for being
there
so all you're allowed to do in the
middle c this is all you can do you sit
still
do not move
do not speak
do not eat
don't put your tray table down don't get
on your laptop don't even read because
that involves moving your elbows this is
all you do the entire time just like
this
do not move i don't care if it's six
hours
anyone
who doesn't follow that rule should be
banned
so that's the first thing i would do
middle c yeah middle c you have you are
basically less of a person
you have no constitutional rights no
rights of any kind because you're
sitting in the middle seat
[Music]
quick uh quick little fitness tip for
you a little bit fitness inspiration i
like to inspire you i don't know if you
knew this on the show i consider myself
a motivational inspirational speaker in
many ways so yesterday i was coming home
from the gym
uh stopped at the gym on the way from
home from work and um you know i've been
going to the gym
pretty regularly feeling good about that
but the problem is that my diet isn't
great i just i eat crap all the time
just a lot of junk food that's that's
the truth
and they say you can't outrun a bad diet
you know you can't work out enough to
compensate for the bad diet you're
always going to be like a net it's
always going to be a net negative
um in the end so i'm on my way home i
was thinking about this and i realizing
if i only had a good diet
i'd be doing well if it was just for the
diet part and i resolved in that moment
i had this like moment in the car
driving home and i resolved they said
i'm gonna start eating healthy
from this moment on
it's gonna happen
not eating junk food i'm not gonna i'm
gonna whatever you're gonna cut back on
carbs
all that stuff
and i was resolved to do it i felt i
just was i felt so motivated
and then i walked in my home
and the first thing my wife said to me
was hey we made brownies
and so i ate half the pan
immediately
and that's when i realized i had a
second epiphany
and i realized as i was eating my third
brownie
i realized you know you can't outrun a
bad diet that's true but you can go for
the tie
and uh you know that's bad that i think
that's good enough right
just kind of maintaining where you're at
that's what i'm going for
[Music]
yeah i just have to say i almost this is
something i almost talked about for the
daily cancellation but then something
else came along that annoyed me more and
so i'm doing that instead
but uh this is this is a something that
has plagued me for for my whole life and
it happened to me again this morning
when i was coming in i was at the at the
stopping the gas station
you know the only thing worse
than someone who doesn't hold the door
for you when you're walking into a
building right behind them
is when somebody holds the door for you
when you're too far away
now i had i was at the gas station i was
practically just getting out of my car
like 25 paces away and this guy looks
back sees that i'm heading towards the
door and holds it for me and i tried to
give him the wave and say no it's fine
go ahead just keep going
and he gives me the way i'll stand here
and so now it's just that awkward walk
where i have to do that sort of half jog
walk to get to the door faster than i
otherwise would have
all for the sake of me not having to
just do this and open it myself i'm
perfectly capable of doing that you
could just keep going
so that is a lot worse
and here's because here's the mistake
people make and this is just the tip i'm
going to give you
walking inside a building it's a very
complicated procedure but here's what
you want to do because if you're walking
into the building and then you look back
you do the check to make sure there's no
one coming in behind you if you catch
eye contact with someone coming in
behind you now you feel like you have to
hold it for them right
and even if they're 20 paces away so
make sure when you look back your eyes
are looking down so you'll catch just
their feet
and then you can make a judgment of how
many paces if it's more than 10 paces
you just keep going let them know open
the door for themselves that's it okay
and at the end of the day if they have
to open the door for themselves it's not
a big deal always err on the side
of being too rude than too polite
that's my tip that's my etiquette tip
[Music]
you know you really got to trust your
instincts uh and so when you hear you
know i always hear these claims from
from from people when they're pushing
like vegan
or soy-based substitutes for real food
or now they're pushing bugs and they're
saying uh you know have a bug burger
made of uh grasshoppers or crickets
tastes just like the real thing
and i never try that stuff but i always
know i'm just like there's no way it
tastes the same it just doesn't
and so yes
this past weekend i i tested the theory
i was at my in-laws house and my
sister-in-law is uh big into
vegan ice cream
i don't think she she hasn't gone full
vegan herself but some of the stuff so
she has this vegan ice cream it was like
mint chocolate
and it looked pretty real
and she was telling me like no it tastes
just you'll never know the difference
it's delicious
and so i tried some of it it was my
first taste of a vegan substitute
and i said i took one spoonful
and it was
horrifying
don't listen to anyone who tries to push
a vegan ice cream on you it tastes you
know what it tasted like
melted chalk
doused in pepto-bismol and splenda
that's what it it was really unsettling
actually that's the word i was trying to
figure out
there's something yeah it's it's
horrible it's bad
it's also kind of creepy it's weirdly
inorganic and inedible
it tasted dyspeptic and and dystopian
even
it's like a ration they might serve in a
prison cell on mars in the year 2075. it
was
really i didn't like it in other words
stick with the real stuff
[Music]
we need to have a very important
conversation about hallway etiquette
now that i'm working here in the office
i expect that this is an issue that will
arise frequently as it does in any
workplace
so i'm issuing a pre-emptive
cancellation of everyone who violates
the rules of hallway adequate etiquette
everyone here at dailywire understands
that if they are canceled by me
or violate one of my rules they must
immediately resign
this i'm pretty sure is written in the
employee handbook at least it's written
in mine because i added it in crayon
now as everyone knows passing by another
human being in a hallway
is a daunting challenge
the problem is that as you both approach
each other you must time your greeting
for exactly the right moment or else
immense awkwardness ensues
if you're still 20 paces apart and you
say hello at that point then you have to
walk the remaining steps having already
issued your greeting
you can't very well greet each other and
then have 15 seconds of silence as you
complete your walk past one another it
would be akin to you know making brief
small talk on an elevator and then
saying bye to the person when you both
still have 10 floors left to climb so
you say all right well good talking to
you see you later
then you're both just standing there for
another 30 seconds we're talking nuclear
levels of awkwardness what this means
that is that if you fire your greeting
round too early in the walk past
somebody in the hallway when you're both
still say 15 seconds apart you must then
have precisely 15 seconds of small talk
to fill the gap
but if the small talk goes on too long
or if one of you says something that
requires a longer answer
now you'll end up stopping and having a
stop in chat which is exactly what you
both want to avoid that's what's what's
at stake here if you get it wrong
you may be stuck having god forbid a
full-on conversation and nobody wants
that
the key then is to wait to acknowledge
the other person until you are exactly
four paces apart
in order to achieve this you must make
sure to avoid eye contact until
precisely the moment when you hit the
four pace threshold
you could accomplish this by looking
down at your phone looking up at the
ceiling staring straight ahead noticing
a smudge on your shoe i have a tendency
of noticing lint on my sleeve
whenever i'm in a hallway with someone
i'll brush at the lint
until we hit four paces and then i look
up and i say oh hey how are you to which
they can respond great how are you and i
can say great great
then i go back to the lint for about
half a beat to sell the ruse boom four
paces have been completed
and i have succeeded in passing by the
person without having a meaningful or
extended interaction which again is the
whole objective now on occasion you may
run into someone who throws this plan
for a loop because
when you say hey how are you they
actually have the audacity to answer the
question honestly
actually telling you how they are as if
you wanted to know
thereby sucking you into a vortex of
conversation that may take minutes to
extricate yourself from
not much you can do about so you know
psychopaths like this except avoid them
at all costs one additional tip
if you really want to avoid talking to
people in hallways or making eye contact
one thing you could try doing is walking
backwards through the hallway
this will have the added benefit of not
only avoiding eye contact and
conversation in hallways but probably in
general too because your co-workers will
think you're a weird freak of course
this can backfire if the other person is
also walking backwards
so you might try somersaulting through
the hallways
this means the other person has to jump
over you but again it avoids
conversation with co-workers
especially after you get fired
one other wrinkle to explore here
briefly what happens when you're out say
at the grocery store
and you pass by an acquaintance
in like the condiment aisle
well you follow the four pace rules as
discussed simple enough
but many of us have been in the crisis
situation
where you pass by the same person again
in the pasta aisle you can't use the hey
how are you line because it's already
been asked and answered now you have to
make a brief joke about the fact that
you already saw them maybe something
like long time no see
or something similar if you pass by them
a third time
you could probably get away with a hey
stop stalking me
but there cannot be a fourth time under
no circumstance can you allow yourself
to pass the person a fourth time
if you end up in the same aisle as them
a fourth time
you have no choice but to drop your
groceries
run in the other direction
change your name move to mexico
these are the rules of passing people in
hallways or aisles
it's very complicated
but they must be strictly observed
[Music]
all right you know i i get accused of
being uh anti-social
mostly because i am
anti-social but one of the reasons why i
get this acquisition is i'm not big into
small talk i'm not a big small talk it's
not that i don't like talking i talk for
a living i just don't i'm not into small
this idea that like any time you're
around someone you have to fill that
space with by making noise with your
mouth it doesn't matter what you're
saying because that's what small talk is
and um it annoys me to no end and i
experienced over the weekend
maybe the worst example of this
in my life
we were we were out uh from memorial day
we were at a lake and i was walking to
the car to get something and i noticed
that my
shoes were untied so i stopped to tie my
shoes
and there was this guy walking by
and we're the only ones in the in the
area for a moment and so he's one of
these small talkers and he feels like
okay in his mind i guess he's thinking
i'm gonna i'm gonna be passing by this
other guy and we're gonna be in the same
vicinity for five seconds and so i have
to say something to him
and so this guy what he says is he
passing by he says
ah tying your shoes huh
he actually said that and i look up and
i said
yep
time my shoes
then he just kept walking
why do people what why do people do that
why
why do you fee
you obviously had nothing to say to me
at all that's perfectly fine just say
nothing keep walking
tying your shoes huh
is that supposed to spark a conversation
and then i feel like the anti-social one
because i don't know how to respond to
that i'm not sure what i'm supposed to
say
is that supposed to be the beginning of
a conversation i don't know
you know they say if you don't have
anything nice to say don't say anything
at all and i don't really agree with
that because if i followed that rule
this show wouldn't exist
um but i think it's more like if you
don't have anything to say period then
don't say anything i don't care if it's
nice or not
only speak when you have something to
say
and then we do away with small talk
entirely
[Music]
so the actress monique recently got
herself into hot water because of
comments she made about the way
according to her
some black women dress and present
themselves in public she was inspired to
offer this criticism after noticing lots
of slovenly attire at the airport she
spoke about the issue for several
minutes and then did a follow-up video
further explaining it but here's some of
the original instagram posts let's watch
and as we begin to walk through the
airport
i saw
so many actually too many to count
and too many for me to tap
but i saw so many of our young sisters
in head bonnets
scarves
slippers
pajamas
blankets wrapped around them and this is
how they're showing up
to the airport
and it
i've been seeing it not just at the
airport i've been seeing it at the store
at the mall i've been seeing sisters
showing up with these bonnets and head
scarves and these slippers
and the question that i'm having to you
my sweet babies
when did we lose pride in representing
ourselves
now after watching that i'm beginning to
think i need to start softening some of
my more controversial takes by calling
the audience sweet babies
seems to work for monique something
tells me it wouldn't work as well for me
as for the point she's making she's
right and this isn't just about black
women this is a problem that extends
equally across all sexes all of them all
95 sexes all races
in fact it's maybe the one thing that
still unites us as americans is our one
source of unity that we dress like hobos
in public especially at airports
airports now look like refugee camps
with people sprout out all over the
place laying across seats on the floor
wrapping themselves in old newspaper
using a half-eaten bag of chips as a
pillow
everyone's wearing pajamas
they have their shoes off exposing their
gnarled fungus crusted toes to the world
it's unseemly disgusting and it's made
all the worse by the fact
that all of us have paid way too much
money for the privilege of being tossed
in with this gang of
foul-smelling circus freaks
now you see this sort of thing
everywhere as monique rightly points out
at the store walking down the street
everywhere
i saw a guy the other day at the grocery
store wearing fuzzy bear slippers
as in slippers
that looked like teddy bears as he
walked around the frozen food aisle
this man was older than me by the way
his attire was an unholy mix of
infantilizing and bedraggled
childish and disheveled
now for comparison
go back and look at old photos taken of
any random
busy pedestrian area in say 1935.
all the men are dressed in hats and
suits all the women are wearing dresses
everybody looks like they just came out
of church all the time
now take that same street and get a
snapshot from
yesterday in the year 2021 and
everyone's adorned like a bunch of
nine-year-olds at a slumber party in
fact get a snapshot of them walking out
of church
what few still attend and they probably
still look like nine-year-olds at a
slumber party
i saw a guy at church recently in a
batman t-shirt and shorts
if that's what he considers dressing up
i'd hate to see what he wears to the
airport probably naked with just a
bathrobe and
socks with no shoes which at least would
make it easier when he goes through
security admittedly of course many
people including monique
have pointed all this out before it's
well known and understood that people go
out in public
looking like half-melted slugs we become
a nation of pajama-clad oafs that much
is known
but what's interesting is to compare
this to the way that people present
themselves online
you know most americans feel comfortable
walking around in a three-dimensional
public space with uncombed hair
unbrushed teeth
sweatpants they just pulled out of a
dumpster
but most of those same people
wouldn't be caught dead
on instagram looking like that
this could be an interesting experiment
if a bit stalkerish but it'd be
fascinating to see
a person you know walking out of target
looking like they were just in there
sleeping on the bathroom floor for the
past nine hours and then find that same
person on instagram and see the sort of
image they put out into the world it is
guaranteed to be quite a bit different
now in fairness
it is easier
requires less effort to present yourself
as well kempt and attractive online
because you only have to worry about
what you look like for the half a second
it takes to snap a picture and then you
can alter it in post if you need to
uh one must expend more energy for a
longer period of time to look suitable
in the real world you have to do things
like
you know shower
iron your shirt put on pants
it's not much effort but it's some
effort and some is more than a lot of
people are willing to give
but i think there's more to it aside
from the effort it seems that these days
we simply don't value in-person
interaction the way that we value our
interactions with avatars online i mean
the classic example of this that
everyone points to all the time and the
most depressing also is the infamous
sight of a family at a restaurant
sitting around a table silently while
they all interact with strangers through
their phones
i think the poor dress in public is part
and parcel with this it speaks to our
inability to recognize the value of
other humans
and of human to human interchange
unless it's mediated by a digital device
it's common to hear someone defend their
embarrassing attire and disgusting
appearance
and it's what some of the people were
saying to monique saying that well you
know i don't care what anyone thinks
it's none of their business
except that you do care what other
people think
you care tremendously
it's just that you only seek approval of
strangers in cyberspace
see it's not a matter of
not caring about people's opinions it's
a matter of which people's opinions they
choose to care about
and for so many they choose the internet
strangers rather than humans that they
encounter face to face
in flesh and blood
and i think that's the wrong choice it's
not just the wrong choice
it's deeply disordered
and dehumanizing
and demeaning
to everybody involved
so please everyone stop walking around
in public looking like hideous unbathed
ogres
my sweet babies
[Music]